hi my name is sergey sadrakian
i'm a junior faculty at the university
of southern california and children's
hospital los angeles
and i thank the organizers for this
invitation and
opportunity to present our work today
i'll
talk about extracellular vesicles and
chronic kidney disease
so what is chronic kidney disease it is
a kidney
disease defined by gradual loss of renal
function
over sometimes extended period of time
it can be years and
you know many years and there are many
different factors that contribute to
the initiation progression of chronic
kidney disease
in human population the two major ones
being diabetes and cardiovascular
problems in addition obesity
you know genetic mutations tobacco use
aging and other factors as well do
contribute to
progression of chronic kidney disease
i will not be exaggerating if i say that
kidney is one of the most complex organs
in the human body
being that it is very heterogeneous in
in nature
structure wise and very difficult to
study so
so the functional unit of the kidney is
the nephron which is composed of the
glomerulus
and and tubules the glomerulus is a
bonus structure that contains
micro capillaries made up of endothelial
cells and petrocytes
as shown in the diagrams in the right
the podocyte is is the is the
is the cell that's highlighted in green
that surrounds the capillary structures
and between the
endothelial cells and and protocide is
the
lies the glomerular basement membrane
and in the electron micrographs on the
bottom
you're seeing a projection of the
glomerulus in a
scanning electron microgram actually on
the left and on the right is a close-up
image
where we can more clearly see the
basement membrane
it's a thin layer of matrix and on both
sides we
have the penetrated endothelial cells
and the podocyte
what's so special about this structure
is that nephron cannot be regenerated in
adult life
so we humans are born with specific
numbers of nephrons
and and they are predetermined usually
that number is
roughly somewhere around between 500 000
to 1 million
per kidney
the glomerular cells namely the
pedocytes and endothelial cells
are very unique in their nature the
podocyte is unique because despite the
fact that it's a typical endothelial
cell
its location architecture its function
are unique uh because they have this
foot processes that make
interdigitations at the filtration
barrier
that determine the permanent selectivity
nature
of the filtration function the
protocytes are
post mitotic cells that means they do
not proliferate
they're not they cannot be replaced and
if they do so that means there is a
problem and usually this happens to ring
disease
they swap off from the basement membrane
which
usually is associated with onset of
protein urea
glomerular endothelial cells are unique
as well because they have
fenestrations and they are responsible
for the first filtration activity
as the ultrafiltrate from the capillary
first has to leave the endothelium then
the basement membrane then through the
pothoside
and lastly the glomerular basement
membrane is unique
and i'm going to highlight this because
this this matrix is
important and plays an important
function uh in the filtration it's
uh composed of collagen type four and a
special collagen that is produced only
by the podocyte
and mutations in this collagen or any
other component of the
matrix can lead to disease and i'll talk
more about this later
so the homeostatic balance between the
glomerular cells and the glomerular
investment membrane
are important for the maintenance of the
ultrastructural integrity and function
of the of this filtration unit and any
alteration of any of these components
can lead to chronic kidney disease
so loss of glomerular function leads to
development of
chronic kidney disease and in the united
states alone there are more than
30 million patients americans who
have the diagnosis for chronic kidney
disease and this is a major burden
financially on the health care system
and
in 2018 alone um the estimated cost for
you know ckd treatment and end central
renal disease treatment
was somewhere around 114 billion
so what are some of the treatments uh
we are not very fortunate because the
only treatments currently available for
patients with renal failure
is either dialysis or kidney
transplantation
so um and and and and the projections
are not uh
looking very good if we look uh in this
graph
we can see that uh between 1999 and 2015
the number of transplantations were
relatively constant you know somewhere
around between 17 to 18 000
uh annually whereas um the number of
patients
in the transplant waiting list waiting
for a donor organ to have a
transplantation has been growing
over the years and and these numbers are
even higher
you know currently so
this is a tabulation of all the
different
you know etiologies or kidney diseases
that lead to eventually
kidney transplantation as you can see
the number is
the number is huge and the conditions
range from
renal cancer to familial conditions
to glomerular sclerosis and
you know even sickle cell anemia can
lead to kidney disease so
the conditions are enormous if
we take a historical look as to where we
stand right now and what are the
opportunities
as i mentioned dialysis and kidney
transplantations are our two main
mainstream therapies for kidney
replacement
but both of these were discovered
[Music]
back back in the 1940s and 1950s
and only in 1983 we had the introduction
of immunosuppressants which
really enhanced the success of kidney
transplantations
you know providing support for the
um you know
against rejection of the transplants
so uh in addition uh treatments for ckd
in addition to
dialysis and transplantation have been
centered on slowing down its progression
by systemic approaches
uh such as using diuretics or ac
inhibitors
which have many side effects and not are
not specifically targeting the
glomerulus
so we are in 2020 now and uh
no new developments in terms of uh
approved therapies
um are known and so
some of the areas that the research uh
is uh
is working on is gene therapy tissue
engineering and regenerative medicine
applications and even some
pharmacotherapy
approaches to to find a new therapy in
addition
[Music]
there is a variety of stem cells and
extracellular vesicles that have
gained a lot of traction in the recent
years and there seems to be some
opportunity here
for finding a new possible
new possible therapy and so
can we our question is can we apply stem
cells or stem cell based
products to target kidney disease
or renal complications
and so over the years we have
took a a specific approach of
using android stem cells for
potential as a potential therapeutic to
treat kidney disease
and in the past we have looked into
using afscs for treatment of acute
kidney disease
as well as as well as chronic kidney
disease
and we have successfully shown that
single injection of amniotic fluid stem
cells
provides renal protection in terms of
morphology and function
as well as survival in these animals and
more recently we've
taken a new approach where we isolated
extracellular vesicles from amniotic
stem cells and we've shown that just
like the afscs
they have they provide similar
protection and in particular
we observed that
vcvs were able to uh protect
endothelial damage uh induced by vgf
signaling
in upward animals and i'll say a little
bit more about this in the next two
slides
so um just like any other cell afscs do
produce a lot of extracellular vesicles
and we
isolated them using ultracentrifugation
and characterize them
by nanosite and
we can say that afc's produce large
quantities of ebs
so that they can be injected in large
number of animals
so by nanosight we characterize their
size to be roughly about
200 nano meters in diameter
so these evs express typical mesenchymal
markers
extracellular markers such as cd9 cb62b
as well as angiogenic markers
such as whichever receptor 1 receptor 2
so these two receptors are important
for later points that i would like i
will make in the
in the next slides in addition these
vesicles also have
a large uh bank of micro rna
uh both pro angiogenic uh and
anti-angiogenic and obviously
anti-antioxidant
micro rna were detected to be much
higher
and this was important as well
so moving forward i'll introduce
the animal model we used which is upward
syndrome to study ckd
this is a genetic and familial disease
that has mutations in the collagen four
off of three four or five chains in our
case our model has a mutation in alpha
five chain
which results in abnormal deposition of
the glomerular basement membrane
leading to progressive loss of renal
function and ultimately kidney failure
in this image you are seeing
again an electron micrograph of the
basement membrane and histology
showing normal morphology of the kidney
and upon the mutation in the collagen
four alpha 5
gene we have a severe disruption in the
basement membrane
as you can see in the projections in the
right and
developing the fibrosis in the
glomerular and tubular compartments
shown by this histology so this leads to
infiltration of immune cells
deposition of cellular matrix scarring
and reduced blood flow
and the reason we are using this
specific mutation is because 85
of human cases um have this specific
alpha fight mutation
so it's a it's a very common whereas the
other mutations are are much more rare
so in addition um we made this
interesting observation that
vgf which is very important for the
maintenance of the glomerular integrity
and specifically the endothelium
and the fenestrations is highly elevated
early on
in alport mice in the glomeruli
and so we were very interested to
understand whether the vesicles which
expressed now which have receptors could
could mitigate this and so we performed
some in vitro
experiments where we cultured
endothelial cells from glomeruli
and we treated them with vgf just to
recapitulate to mimic the conditions
that
exist in the alport glomeruli and uh
treated them with
normal evs and evs that were
knocked down for regia receptor one and
interestingly we observed that the the
normal leds were able to capture
or binds to vgf in the media and
and prevent this vgf from being taken
out by the cells
and subsequently we performed some
further analysis
looking into the cells and did some
immune precipitation assays where we
confirmed that
there's a direct interaction between vgf
uh and the receptors expressed on the
surface
of the evs so this was important
but then it was also important for us to
understand whether the evs once injected
in in mice could really
you know home to the kidneys so in
collaboration with dr bisellati in the
university of torino
we we performed these experiments where
the evs were injected in mice and
we could uh easily detect them in the
kidneys
and and and image them by
bioluminescence
as shown in this in this uh figure
next obviously uh was uh also important
to understand
whether they have any therapeutic
potential and so we
looked at the you know renal function in
terms of creating an albumin urea
and interestingly with one single
injection
we could see a significant improvement
uh in both of these parameters
so moving forward our ultimate goal was
eventually to
to be able to translate this technology
and so our next steps in
as we move forward we switched from
using old mouse system
where we had the mouse model and using
mouse cds to a mouse and human hybrid
model where we now
use the still use the same mouse upwards
in your model but
apply a human ifsc derived extracellular
vesicles
to understand thereby distribution
therapeutic
effect and mechanisms of action as well
as understand mechanisms of disease
progression
in these animals so um
in this um you know for this aim we
developed uh
you know certain certain directions
namely three specific directions that we
aimed our studies on uh in in one
direction we developed
key assays to allow for consistent
characterization of
this human evs now derived from
consented donors
and evaluate their potential for
clinical you know translation or
application
in the second direction we really
thought about the possibility of
actually expanding these ideas you know
to clinical scale so
we we employed the gmp compatible 3d
hello fiber bioreactor to be able to
meet this need and then
finally we are also developing a
non-invasive clinically applicable
vivo tracking system for evs using mri
to evaluate you know potential homing
and associated toxicity
toxicities in undesired of target organs
or tissues
that will eventually combination of
these three approaches will allow
a successful you know translation
so looking into the key assays
and there are three of them the first
one is looking at
their identity and purity size
distribution
production and characterization by their
cargo
looking at the protein and micro rna
second assay is the potency assay in
vitro where we look at the
functionality of the evs specifically
looking at the capability of these to
trap vgf
as i showed earlier and then lastly look
at their
therapeutic efficacy in vivo where we
isolate glomeruli in injected mice and
look at pgf modulation
analyze gene regulation by rna-seq and
of course
functional changes
so looking at the the first assay where
we do the identity and purity
uh we we characterize the evs by
nanosight
just like the mouse ones and we
determine their size and distribution
and concentration
we also employed a x exo view
technology where we're able to visualize
the evs based on their expression of
tetris plannings the cd9
63 and 81 and we can really um
this technology allows is a combination
of flow cytometry and
you know immunohistochemistry that as i
said allows visualization
as shown in the right we can you know
see really single singularly these and
identify the expression of specific
markers in addition to
tetraspanning and really understand that
heterogeneity so this allows us to
easily characterize
um factorize them so in addition
we looked at surface markers um as i
said the cells are coming from
concentric donors so
in this example we're looking at two
samples
um clonal clonally derived extracellular
vesicles from two concentric donors
compared to the mesenchymal stem cells
and as you can appreciate these two
independent
consented lines have very similar
expression profile
[Music]
so next uh we we looked at their protein
cargo and micro rna
obviously by rna sig and mass spec
and in this diagram you are seeing the
10 most highly expressed proteins in
micro
microrna
i should say that we identify 675
intact proteins in this glomeruli and
2535 microrna were expressed
and these profiles really allow us to to
uh
you know put a fingerprint or on on the
evs that
characterizes or um puts that puts an
identity tag
that we we were able to
uh kind of identify and characterize
them each time we have a new line
uh so uh from our experience we're able
and from our experience using the
culture methods and isolation methods
and characterization
methods we're able to get consistent
lots of human evs
yielding the same features uh as
highlighted
so next thing i want to point out is
that when you compare the
our data from the human evs and mouse
uvs there is an 80
overlap in terms of protein expression
and which
confirms the validity of our derivation
method from the proteome analysis
we in the human sample we also
confirm the absence of hla dr cd80 and
cd86
so this is important in terms of
immunogenicity
and sequencing rna sequencing also
confirmed
that the humanities do not carry the
major microrna involving adaptive and in
making responses uh such as mir
24 155 so this is important as we move
as we move forward
using the human eps so our i'll say
number two
is the potency assay in vitro where uh
which i talked about
for the mice uh and so the same was
applied here
and the fetal cells glomerular
endothelial cells were cultured
and um you know treated with vgf
to mimic the condition that we have in
our globalized
and then the human evs were applied and
and and very similar to
what the myocds did uh we were so in the
military chain of egf protein or
decrease of egf
protein in this assay and
in the in the follow-up or subsequent
experiment
we we performed the same assay without
the cells
without the confounding factor of cells
and again we observe the direct
interaction
between the vgf and the human evs uh
confirming
that the potency of the human derived
evs
being similar if not better than the
maps so this was very encouraging
and then lastly looking at the in vivo
efficacy of the human derived tvs
in this experiment 2.8
times to the 10 our evs were injected
into the 2.5 months age old upward mice
and as you can see the single injection
significantly improved pgf
activity or activation in isolated
glomeruli
in this example and lastly we also
measured the protein urea in this
animals
and again injection of the human evs
significantly ameliorated protein urea
10 weeks time period after the injection
so moving forward i'll give you a little
bit information about the rna-seq
analysis we performed so mice that were
injected with the evs
and mass that were injected not injected
we
isolated their glomeruli one week after
the injection
and and sent for rna sequencing and this
is the data
that is being projected in this pca plot
as you can see the wild type
samples on the left the anim the
the deceased alport mice with the green
are you know separating very nicely
uh in this 2d plot whereas the injected
uh samples shown in blue are really
separating
from both and they are actually
improving at least in one dimension
on the y-axis so this is very
encouraging because we're seeing
some effect we performed a lot of
comparative analysis between all the
groups
and to understand and the differences in
similarities and how the injection of
eps
is really changing or shifting the
pathways in
in the glomerular cells and so very
briefly
looking at some pathway enrichment
analysis we identify the key mechanisms
uh or or you know um mechanisms or
pathways that are affected in upward
glomeruli compared to normal and also
looking at the injected animals we now
understand some of the mechanisms that
might be involved in in
you know leading to improvement in renal
function and
uh as we look further here i'm showing
just two examples in the lipid
metabolism panel and cell matrix
citation molecules and
shown in red with red dots you can see
the
number of genes that are being modulated
or reversed to normal in this glomeruli
so you know
in addition to lipid metabolism and
matrix addition there are some other
areas uh
where the evs are are actively um
you know having a positive effect and we
are you know continuously studying this
this mechanisms so next uh
i will talk about the 3d holofiber
bioreactor
[Music]
studies that we are conducting so
we know that ev clinical translation is
limited
by scale up as i said and hello fiber
bioreactor can support culturally large
number of cells at high densities
and can produce large number of bbs and
so in collaboration with uh
fiber cell systems we are um
we are culturing the you know human
consented
afscs and as you can see in this in this
in this figure
i apologize for the you know low
resolution but
the cartridge that's shown in the in the
front is loaded with afscs and
uh and and fed uh you know by by media
and and without having to passages cells
over a very long period of time
we can continuously harvest large number
of uh opvs
and and so amniotic fluid stem cell evs
grown in this cartridge produce
produced biochemically and functionally
equivalent uh
evs uh similar to the you know 2d
derived dvds that we
grow in in our culture room
and with yields that can support
clinical scale and gmp
compatible system and so just like with
the 2d
evs growing our you know uh
lab we performed the same assays for the
reactive derived tvs and as you can see
in this in this figures
the uh the potency assay was not any
less than the 2d derived
was even better and the improvement in
proteinuria was
was much more better than with a 2d
system so
this is very encouraging and we're
looking forward to
to improving this even even further
so next i will talk about the uh the
next uh
the direction or next area we are
advancing
or working towards is the is the mri
detection
of evs um
using um using special dyes or
more specifically iron particles
uh to study biodistribution and
potential homing and
you know of target associated toxicities
and etc
and so mri
is is an important modality
but before i go to the mri i should
mention that there are other modalities
imaging modalities
currently available such as optical
imaging um
through bioluminescence and fluorescence
imaging nuclear imaging
that can potentially uh be used for
tracking
uh evs in vivo but they are you know
both of these have
certain limitations mainly due to the
you know safety concerns because
one involves radio isotopes and uh
optical imaging
requires transfections plasmids and
fluorescent dyes and so
in contrast magnetic imaging or mri
is much safer because it uses only
iron particles and
provides excellent special resolution
that can be used to
identify where the evs are so
in collaboration with this is cell
medical
and that specializes in mri cell and
detracting
technologies we're testing the
possibility of using mri to study
biodistribution in vivo
so we performed a few concept studies
demonstrating that a vmi labeling agent
is safe on cells and ev's production and
does not affect their viability
as shown in the first panel
that the label cells or evs can be
detected with electron micro microscope
as shown by the electron dense
projections
in panel c and importantly this labeling
agent does not
affect the size distribution and
production levels of
evs as we confirmed with nanoside
tracking and importantly
we can use relaxometry to to measure the
con
the iron content in these vesicles and
importantly
uh the labeled tvs can also be uh
visualized with mri
so to test the in vivo tracking
potential of the vmi die we injected
healthy and controlled mice
with with the evs with a single dose we
are two different routes
one was the retro orbital route and
intracardiac route was applied
my mice were imaged once before the
injection
and 30 minutes post-injection and as you
can appreciate from the
from the uh from this uh projections
a positive signal was detected only in
the output mice
injected via the intracardiac route that
is nicely shown in the blow-up
projections of the renal cortices in the
right
our mri findings were further confirmed
by tissue histology and as you can
appreciate in this
micrographs persian blue staining is
observed only in the kidney injected
with the endocardia grout
and not through the retro-orbital route
and it's only present in the diseased
tissue and not in the control and
control mice so intracardiac delivery of
evs to the damaged kidneys more
efficient than iv
route and and we know that that disease
really
contributes to the homing of the you
know evs or cells
uh and to the to the target organ
and so um this is an important step
moving forward as
uh you know understanding the by
distribution
homing of any reagent that's being
injected into the human organism
is important and needs to be needs to be
well documented
so with this i would like to conclude by
stating that our protocol for human evs
derivation
is reproducible and allows for
derivation of
a large number of ev lots with uh with
similar identity and purity and potency
and that human direct dives shows strong
in you know efficacy
as shown by our assays and that the
production of large number of these
using the 3d bio
hollow fiber bioreactor system uh
is similar to if not better
than the 2d derived humanities
from our culture you know laboratory
cultures
and that the combination of mri
technology and the vmi
you know tracking system uh
is a highly applicable technology
for real timing for tracking of evs that
can ultimately
shift the paradigm in you know in safety
and so with this i would like to
conclude and thank everybody in our
you know research group for their
individual contributions
i would like to thank our contributors
for their uh
for their support and with the
experiments with their ideas
and and you know advice
and ultimately to all our
funding agencies for their support thank
you
i'll take any questions